[Music]
what I'm gonna talk about is a project
which which we're doing at Berkeley
having to do with building a programming
interface for a database system and in
particular it's for the next-generation
extensible relational system being built
at Berkeley by the name of Postgres this
is the follow-on to the ingress project
that mike Stonebraker and i were doing i
will mostly today talk about the
programming front-end system that we're
building and this has really work in
progress so so this is not I will tell
you at the end what's completed and
what's not first off the goals for this
system object fads fad stands for forms
application development system it's a
third system in a series that I've been
building for the last six eight years
where you build applications by filling
in forms in those forms then cause
pieces of the application to be built
this system is going to be on on a
workstation interface multiple window
mouse interface graphical data and
program display all these good things
after working for a while it's pretty
clear you want an object-oriented
programming environment and my real goal
was to build something that was portable
that we could pass around to a lot of
different people to use and so we've
decided to use common lisp as the
implementation language we're using
common loops as the object hierarchy
system we actually got the PCL
implementation from Xerox and have been
using that the database portion of this
is that we're going to make that object
hierarchy or a part of that object
hierarchy be shared across multiple
workstations so that the programs can
access objects but those objects might
might be persistent and might be
simultaneously referenced and accessed
by other workstations in terms of the
programming environment the specific
stuff that we're working on is an
extensible form system from the database
world a form is what you see on a screen
and we've built a couple of these and
and they've pretty much been static
beasts and we want to make it extensible
and I'll say something more about that
later then lastly the the model that we
use for describing these chunks of
application that get Bill
is a notion of a frame and we're going
to make the system extensible in that
dimension as well and I won't have
chance to talk very much about that
because of the time rather I'm going to
focus on the software architecture and
interconnection to the X Window manager
this is what the world will look like
inside the machine there'll be multiple
processes centered around this list
process and within the list process you
have to have some concept of sub
processes you're gonna have multiple
windows on the screen and you want to
have a concept of a chunk of Lisp code
bound to a particular window so we have
multiple what we're calling sub
processes and an event driven scheduler
in there to to pass events to it so Lisp
interfaces to the X server which
displays the windows up on the screen in
addition we're using Emacs as our editor
environment and we've built an interface
between Emacs and the Lisp system such
that the window objects which we've
defined in the PCL hierarchy can either
be X window objects up here or they can
be Emacs buffers so it's possible for
you to write Lisp code that takes takes
events and data from one of those list
buffers and goes off and manipulates it
as well what we plan to do with that is
to eventually do things like have the
debugger when it wants to dump the stack
trace actually just pass that stack
trace up to an Emacs buffer and then let
you search it and play with it up there
on the other side there's an interface
to Postgres which is the database system
and then it has to manage access to the
disk and the database system has some
additional processes that it has to deal
with which is the post master post
master essentially the startup daemon if
you will for starting up Postgres --is
so that's what the system architecture
looks like a little bit of details about
some of the pieces and what we've built
essentially we've have an
object-oriented interface to X and we've
implemented it very similarly in spirit
to the system that was described just in
the last talk we took in foreign
function interface the X live interface
into the lisp that
using we're using extended common list
from Fran's Inc and we've got it both on
sons and on vaccin and we moved the list
process around to one place or another
depending on where we can find some free
cycles in fact last week we got our 8800
working and the students working on the
project tell me that the world's best
personal machine is to have a son three
up front with a lot of memory on it
connected to the 8800 and they run the
list process back on the 8800 so I hope
they don't find out about the Cray in
the basement or the what we've done with
PCL is that we've actually defined a
bunch of objects which correspond to the
kind of high level objects you'd like to
have like display objects window objects
fought objects we have a very primitive
set of menu things we also act a foreign
function interface in the X menu package
as well we have a concept of events in
the environment and we're working on the
forms objects which which I'll talk
about in a bit we've built in and in
where we're in the process of building
an object browser for the PCL object
hierarchy and we could actually I saw
the other day an actual hierarchy
displayed on the screen and the idea is
kind of a standard sort of thing where
you can button the objects and take a
look at the instance variables class
variables methods and the like and edit
them and that sort of thing the thing
that we've we've gotten running that's
that's kind of the core of the system is
this event driven scheduler
basically we have multiple windows
connected to a list sub process and as I
mentioned before these processes can
have access to an X mat x window or
Emacs buffer the interesting thing about
the way the scheduler works is that we
get events convert them into PCL objects
of type event and then we do have just a
straight method call and that does the
determination of which event handler to
to call and I'll show an example of this
on the next slide in addition the
scheduler handles a primitive concept of
global and local variables now the
scheduler currently is written in kind
of neutral Common Lisp so we don't do
preemption or anything like that
and the reason for that is that I'm
really trying to build a system that
will be ultimately portable the comment
that the previous speaker made is
absolutely true around Berkeley if I
wander around the halls and look at what
sort of workstations there are we seem
to get one of most and so in the past we
did real well by having portable code
that wouldn't run across them and so
that's why if you notice in most of my
decisions it's what we're doing we're
doing it with portable public domain
types of code just briefly to show you
how someone would code a subprocess
here is an example of a part of the
event hierarchy you have the event and
then the X event and for example you
could have a keydown event or a button
press event and to define a particular
sub process say p1 all you have to do is
define a method that takes an argument
of whatever the events are that you'd
like to to catch and so the collection
of those methods in a sense defines the
process the sub process and what the
scheduler does is to take the events
from the server in through X Y pass it
through this thing that converts the
event to a PCL object hands that PCL
object off to the scheduler schedule
looks up the window sub process binding
and then just does a straight method
call to get to the correct code within
that thing and that works fine for
events that don't happen real frequently
but for events like pressing the key if
you had to if you had to create a PCL
object and do a method call on every key
pressed the the 8,800 would be reduced
to rubble in terms of performance so one
of the things that we've done is that
for events which are essentially
collecting up larger objects if you have
a sequence of characters you're
collecting into an S expression or if
you're filling in a form and you have a
sequence of characters that go into one
field what we're going to do is have
that event handle we're going to custom
code those in a way that after they get
the first X event through the PCL
hierarchy they'll turn around and ask
the the lower-level interface does too
to get more events of that same type
without having to create the the PCL
object and pass it on
so essentially an optimization try to
make that go faster and we actually have
the scheduler running and a text window
and we even had a lisp listener window
up and that sort of thing
and it runs it runs acceptable
performance I wouldn't say it's blazing
fast but it was certainly acceptable
interactive behavior
okay the shared object hierarchy this
part is not is not really done yet so
this is really futures basically what
we're gonna do is define in PCL a meta
class called DB class and then anytime
you define a class which is of class DB
class then objects of that instance will
in fact be stored out in the database
system and what we're gonna have to do
in the lisp system is maintain an object
cache to fetch objects from the database
system into this object cache and I've
written a paper on a design for that
object cache including prefetching and
some pre-computation of the of the
objects which are being stored out in
the database system since they are they
are going to be normalized into a
tabular representation distributed cache
update and some some ideas on
transaction management for objects so
anybody who's interested in that paper
on shared object hierarchies or Postgres
send me mail at Berkeley and we'll be
glad to send you a copy of that design
let's see when do I have to tell you can
try and make me give it all back okay
let's talk a bit about the form forms
interface and the kinds of visual
programming tools that we're trying to
build just so that we all understand the
same thing by a form here's the form
displayed on a screen it's what you
would think if you were doing a paper
form on the display and these forms can
get very complex and here's just a small
listing of the kinds of complexity that
you have first off the form is composed
of all sorts of different fields where
data is entered and displayed so here we
have a field where you enter name here
is something that looks kind of like a
table down here in this table obviously
should be scrollable left right and that
sort of thing
now these components in here can be
various things they can be trimmed like
employee information up there which
doesn't change labels like the label
associated with a field which instantly
if you want to pick this field up and
move it elsewhere you really want to get
both the label and the field itself and
then you have the actual data field
where the data is entered and displayed
in any form system worth its salt you've
got to have a bunch of facilities for
display enhancements font blinking color
dot in fact that list seems to go on
forever in addition you want to have all
sorts of usage characteristics about
those various fields so if for example
you're doing data entry you want a
concept of a mandatory field so that if
someone is entering values that they're
forced to put a value there sometimes
when you're using the display or the
form for output you want to display a
value you want to say look I'll display
a value in this field but you're not
supposed to be able to update it so it's
a display only field and there's a lot
of other usage characteristics in
addition you can have a concept of an
active form we're doing things in the
form can in fact cause computations to
be done so for example leaving a field
you might want to invoke an edit check
entering the value of a name might want
to spawn a computation to go look up the
street and sitting city address and the
like okay well there's what you got to
do if you're going to do a form system
and what we're trying to do is is to
satisfy two constraints which I haven't
seen a system that's satisfied before
which is one we want to make the form
system extensible which is to say that
you can put in new kinds of fields in
the form but we also want to build a
WYSIWYG it interface for allowing you to
define these forms and so here is a set
of abstractions of objects for
describing these various components in
the field that we're off implementing
first off the the composition is going
to be that everything is a form so you
can have character forms text forms
bitmap forms graphics forms there's kind
of the primitives then you have
structured form types so you can have a
collection form which is what that
previous slide was showing table form
showed one of those and here's one that
that everybody's seen and it's hard to
figure out how to model but a variant
form where essentially if you enter
value into one
into one field it will cause one or more
of the variants to be displayed so the
obvious example is I suppose view inner
marital status that asks for information
related to different marital status or
or if you're married
maybe you asked for a spouse's name or
something then you have if you're in the
if you're in the business racket or
statistical racket you get these
crosstab forms where there's variability
in the data down the column as a row as
well as across the top which are pretty
common now the thing we're trying to
build is something that will allow you
to do a form kind of like this excuse my
poor drawing essentially where you can
nest things inside of other things so
you have a standard kind of master
detail form and here you have a table
but the rows of the table can can in
fact contain these more complex objects
so here we have say personnel and a
department you have a name and then
within this one column you have another
table field that lists performance
evaluations or reviews or something and
just show we're gonna do graphics you
can put a bitmap over there that shows
the person's picture as well but the
thing that we've got to do when you
could build this sort of beast today and
there's been several lists programming
systems that have built object-oriented
user interface mechanisms but they don't
really have at least I haven't seen
WYSIWYG forms editors what you really
want to be able to do is you want to be
able to say gee give me a give me a
bitmap form right there and and it will
then drop it up there you say well gee I
don't like it there let's move it over
here let's change this thing so that you
really get a
what-you-see-is-what-you-get editor for
these forms objects so what we're doing
is trying to define what the
abstractions are for objects of type
form and then build the editor that
would operate on those kinds of things
so that we can build forms forms
interfaces
okay just for advertising sake let me
put up the the one-page description of
what Postgres is this is a the new
database system that we're building it's
going to be an extensible relational
DBMS and extensible in the sense it's
going to support data types and access
method extensions one of the big things
in the database racket is a problem
having to do with support for complex
objects and in particular Mike and I
have this idea for how to support
complex objects in the database system
by supporting procedures as built-in
types which can be stored in fields in a
table in addition some pre computation
and caching which is what we're going to
use to support this shared object
hierarchy I described earlier mentioned
earlier from the database perspective
the world looks like there are these
great AI expert systems and you can
build very sophisticated expert systems
but they operate on in core databases
and you talk to people who are building
commercial strength AI applications and
they say gee I've got this great expert
system over here that works on this in
core database and I've got this 10
megabyte database over here on the disk
how do I get those two guys together and
so one of the things that we're looking
at is how to provide support for rules
and inferences in the database system
and it turns out that there's a nice way
that you can use some mechanisms that
are already found in most database
systems triggers and learners to support
forward and backward chaining priorities
and a notion of early versus late
evaluation which really factors in the
pre computation another thing in the
database world that you really need is
version control and historical data
support basically it's going to be a a
right once storage system so that in
fact you can roll the database back to a
previous state and look at it or you can
ask queries that involve time time
series so give me names of all employees
have gotten more than the 10% raise in
the last six months and the hardware
technology that both the database system
and the front-end are based on is is a
notion that optical discs are here to
stay and we want to support optical
discs but probably more importantly is
that this tightly coupled
multiprocessors that we see a
a lot of people building the spirt
project at Berkeley is one example of
such a beast and so one of the things
we're doing in the design is we're
saying well let's spawn a lot of
processing in the background to take
advantage of all those extra processors
because we don't know how mean the
system is talking about building 610
processor workstations and it's not
clear how you take standard UNIX
programs and run them on six ten ten
processor workstations okay here's
something that tells you what the
currents that it is status is next
Tuesday we got a big demo of both
Postgres and some of the front end that
will execute essentially the the back
end at this point execute the the core
of the query language doesn't work on
the historical storage system yet but it
does do all the query and kind kinds of
things query optimization and access
methods and light the object VADs
environment we've got the Lisp server
running the X Window manager interface
we have PCL objects for windows fonts
events all these kinds of things the
Emacs integration works we have the
primitive object browser we've also got
a low-level implementation of two
Postgres that we can actually take data
from the database and what they're
working on this week and hopefully we'll
get done is ability to take that data
from the database and actually show it
through a form so that you can actually
do data entry and browsing through the
form so that's where we are our
intention is to get these two systems
working well enough that we can actually
send them around to other people in fact
we've already sent around the the
foreign function interface of X into
Franz common list and we're perfectly
happy to send that to anybody who wants
just sending mail to me at Berkeley
again and we'll be glad to send it and
probably sometime late this summer we'll
have enough of the rest of the system
that we can actually send that out as
well
okay questions
the only code that I am aware of that's
that's that's non-standard is the
foreign function interface part and so
we plan around Berkeley if I count
machines okay there are a lot of sons
relative a relative number of micro
boxes and one each of everything else
and so we plan to port it to the deck
common list basically when they get
their act together get the thing
debugged and running a little bit better
so that so we can do it we actually are
using my one micro vex on the project
but if somebody else wants to take it
and do the foreign function interface
changes you know we're perfectly willing
to send them to you and help you no
problem we're using the new Macs in fact
I think somebody before was asking about
mapping Mouse events into whatever I
think that works in canoe max I mean
okay so get good new max then that's all
taken care of okay thank you
[Applause]
I'll send you look like
you know
you can use that for asking otherwise I
put it on
if we're we're all ready because I'm
ready my name is Greg Coleman and I'm
from locals computing Corporation and
the work we're doing involves to two
things and I've titled it Doss in a
window on system five or at least three
3d6 UNIX system actually let me say a
few more words it was at the overview
level what we have is the ability to one
run X Windows on a small machine that
looks like an IBM PC 80 it actually has
a 3d 6 processor and we can run a Doss
task in a window in this system
essentially you can have a C : prompt
and run dos programs you hear a little
bit more about that later on
so the the effort very independent
efforts of the port itself to the system
5 released 3 kernel and the development
of a client process that interacts with
the the vm 86 tasks to allow it to be
displayed and to provide keyboard input
to the dost ask
the development environment for the task
we actually started with an early
release of a kernel an alpha part of the
kernel there are some functionality not
available that influenced some of the
choices we made in our implementation
this is like I said system five release
three as ported to the 3d six system and
actually ported by interactive systems
corporation we used an Intel 310 based
system for much of the development work
that's our main workhorse system the 3d
six processor is very fast so the small
system offers approximately five times
the CPU performance of a VAX 750
although the disks and so forth are are
not of the same comparable capabilities
the axel target machine again was a 80
compatible machine that with an Intel 3d
6 processor
the port involved there's a few changes
to UNIX to allow us to work system
system five release three was the the
first system Phi system inherently had
some of the features that are very
important to make a system like X work
in X the all the it depends on the
essentially a synchronous event
processing in the clients and server and
system five release three now has a pole
system call that was used as the basis
to make all this work but it did not
support polling on devices we had to we
chose to extend the polling support to
include devices essentially you could
choose to write device driver with very
few changes to make it be polar Bowl we
had we modified the the PTY driver and
they and the device drivers that we
wrote they were part of the
virtualization of the real mode a day
six machine the vkb d is a virtual
keyboard device and we had a display
device and and the actual device it's
VCT CRT which is the device a unix
device that connects to the virtual Dass
display some of this will be explained a
little bit more later we also took a
little more work to add the shared
memory support in the to communicate
between the the X server and the display
and a keyboard actually mostly I guess
it is you know for the Mouse events and
for the keyboard events communication to
the server had to make some changes to
the memory management portions of the
kernel
okay
the server changes most many of them had
to do with the fact that we had to
change the inter process communication
from TCP or decnet to a streams based
system there's a simple streams device
that's actually distributed with the SP
r3 kernel that is used for the IPC and
of course it only works within within
the processor and does not there's not a
while networking the networking support
was not available in the kernel when we
started the project and so that was not
an option
to use actually use the networking the
essentially tp4 type transport layer
that they have and of course the event
processing we essentially wrote an
emulation of select using a pole system
call to avoid the the changes to the
code as much as possible the last item
is something that many people might find
objectionable about that we did but we
actually have a capability of allowing
the DOS tasks to get a special type of
full screen to full screen display where
attaches directly to it since we have
large bodies of dossed application
programs that manipulate the display
directly and translating those through
the X system is difficult or impossible
or at least takes large amounts of CPU
cycles this some of this will also be
explained a little bit more later
the X live changes again mostly confined
to the stuff associated with
inter-process communication and the
polling and the you know essentially the
event processing and handling much of
the rest of a you know ported over with
with minor changes and and allowances
for the different different operating
systems
mm x-term of course one of the first
applications reported again nothing
terribly difficult a few that required a
good understanding of what was going on
with the you know setting up the
controlling terminal and so forth that
it's sort of mysterious in a UNIX world
but you know people a lot of people been
through it and you know if you've been
through it then it's fairly easy to
figure out for those of you that
probably have never looked at this you
have no idea what I'm talking about but
all the other thing I will say is that
the X term was used as a basis for the
product that process we call it X dos
for the PC with a monochrome display
much of what has to happen with X term
and we called X das was was very similar
the the X term essentially has a virtual
terminal implemented within it it would
save the state of the terminal and uses
that to update the the window display
and with X das you have a PC you know
display memory area that sort of
corresponds to the the virtual display
implemented in X term and so we used you
know most of X term in the process that
that's for character oriented displays
when we made it when they went to
support even some graphics display or
graphics das devices there's less use
from the basic X term
I keep wanting to flip these over so I
talked a little bit about the nature of
the display that we were using because
that ends up being fairly important to
some of the stuff later on it's not near
as not as many pixels pixels as a Sun
display for example it's basically like
taking a fourth of a Sun display or
something
and this was the highest resolution
available as a standard PC display and
it's adequate in that respect but
certainly larger displays I believe are
needed and will will be coming before
too long it has when I'm using color
mode it actually has four planes and
they actually occupy the same address
space and one has to do I Oh operations
to address at different planes it makes
it very difficult to get
high-performance operation of course the
other thing contributing to that is the
fact that the display is actually a byte
or in a display I mean it works on a an
88 based IBM PC and it also is sort of
inherently slow because it's designed so
you not to wait for retrace or blanking
to do updates which implies it inserts
wait States as necessary to coordinate
the activities of the CRT controller and
the main processor so when you have a
very fast process of trying to dry this
thing we have sort of a bottleneck
they're actually getting to the display
we actually have color working and it
works you know four times slower than
monochrome basically and the monochrome
was marginally fast enough as it was the
device is the actual programming of the
vises is not very well documented it's
one of these devices with you know
thousands of registers slight
exaggeration but and and there's always
a few bugs in a documentation where it
doesn't do exactly what it says and you
have to find out the hard way
you know disassemble some code here and
there to see how someone else did it
whatever
and and the Iowa instructions are a
problem because normally the i/o
instructions are privileged and you see
you're got to do a some kind of a system
call to do that operation whereas the
actual display updates we have mapped
into the process memory space and so we
didn't have to pay any penalty for that
type of operation
some on cert - you know what we did for
the X EGA lib the the device driver is
modeled after I think we actually
started with like QV SS or something as
one is available and you know we it just
maps in the display to the user to the
server's address space also provides
this direct direct access to the screen
memory cancel that last statement Jimmy
just just I was trying to apply
something it was incorrect huh yeah this
is what sets up the mapping so the
server can access the physical display
and establishes the shared memory for
the event queue that's used to pass
events to the server this the support
for direct screen attachment is the
thing I alluded to earlier where a Doss
task can be given to full display the
way it's done is we actually have a
virtual EGA device as part of the daus
task and we can essentially plug that
into the physical display and
essentially unplug it also so we can
allow the daus
direct access to it next windows
services spins and knows about when this
is happening and can revoke that when it
needs to the keyboard driver we did make
it part of the same driver like was
suggested there's not too much
and can I explain it a little bit well
the basic portion is a Doss client one
question is you know it I'm gonna
explain a little bit more about what the
how the daus environment is set up and
what merge 3d6 is about and then how the
daus client communicates with the VM 86
tasks the Doss client is a client like
most any other X client except for the
fact that it communicates with this
different type of UNIX tasks merge 3d6
provides a virtual pc 80 on this unique
system the processor itself has a basic
support necessary to virtualize in 88 6
to 86 or 36 operating in the real mode
or unprotected mode real where their
dressing is real mode addressing the
product allows integration migration
lots of people who grow up in a UNIX may
be and still carry over their their
favorite applications and if things are
used to or for people that don't want to
leave das it allows them to use the DOS
environment on a UNIX system so das
programs can operate on a UNIX system
with integrated file system the das
files are UNIX files is what its way it
looks and this is done by essentially
mapping the das system calls in a UNIX
system calls with a server process
the virtual machine monitor monitor for
the PC three basic parts you've got the
emulation of the privileged instruction
sets and you've got then the device
emulation you have to build all these
devices they're normally part of a PC
and software several those in have to
interact with the X client and you have
the integrated filesystem which is
provided by a system called redirector
now the Doss client the way it operates
it basically this is sort of the
simplified version it reads from the
Virtual PC display and and then updates
the the Windows display the X Windows
display by making excellent call X live
calls and then similar and fairly simple
in terms of keyboard events it accepts
keyboard events and one thing different
here than other things it has to get the
kyboot the scan codes ultimately have to
deliver scan codes to the das task that
includes not you know key press key
release events and turns out X was
actually it's fairly easy to adapt this
to make this all work it's something
that when we first looked at it might
have been pretty scary trying to make
this all work but it was very easy to do
we haven't completed yet we want to set
it up so that Mouse events can be
focused on a dos task so that
essentially the mouse will be available
to the DOS task and be translated and
passed into a mouse device driver the
Dass expects
yeah
the I'm going to talk mostly about the
display aspects of this interface
because that's the most interesting one
really out of them the other ones the
the way the keyboard is handled is
fairly straightforward and not too
interesting whereas currently handling
two types of displays one the the
monochrome or character on a display and
the other a color graphics adapter which
is a basic alone resolution color
adapter and it's basically the basic
subsystem consists of you know the
display memory and a CRT controller so
essentially our virtual machine has you
know display memory allocated in the
what appears to be the normal place in a
PC for the display memory essentially
the the Doss environment is built with
everything appearing in its normal place
and the CRT controller essentially is a
software virtualization so that all i/o
operations trap and cause updates to the
state of the virtual CRT controller okay
then there's a UNIX device that
interfaces to this display subsystem and
the basic method approach it uses them
to update the X Windows display is we
use the page dirty bits to detect that a
dost task is actually written to the
display that may be the only indication
we have that das program is written to
display because they do direct many das
programs right directly to the display
memory for the character orange this
monochrome type displays we actually
copy the essentially 25 by 80 columns
and rows of characters to make a copy of
it and determine what has changed from
the previous copy to the Curt
be and use that information than to
update the the display before the color
their graphics display rather which we
we don't support in color mode but we
support essentially a limited grayscale
capability of graphics programs and
they're slightly different algorithm but
the principle is the same you detect
areas of screen that have changed and
then update those reasons on the using
ex lib calls the the Dass the DOS client
is not involved in setting up the
virtual 8086 environment there's other
things that take care of that it's just
sort of started up with its task of
communicating with the X server the the
keyboard is handled and the mouse and
then fullscreen attached especially
those that's the set of events and
things that are that X the X dost task
does in this system are there any
questions I have a few minutes left
Oh question was did I do anything about
the aspect ratio differences yes and no
it turns out for the character oriented
you can use whatever fonts you want and
the they become sort of it's sort of
hidden and irrelevant it actually just
doesn't look too bad squished up
whatever mounts to is stuff that would
have been full on a CGA the the EGA has
about twice the resolution so you end up
with it taking about twice as much space
and and so no we didn't try say doubling
every pixel or hang like that though we
considered it that may have to be dealt
with if the characteristics of this play
vary greatly
how big is your page size we've been
happy we've been happy been small but
it's it's 4k it's very tightly wired
into the architecture of the chip
because we want to detect which line
which which lines have changed and and
do minimal yeah yeah and it turns out
for the monochrome display they only
have the the the page is so large we
only have one one the whole page fits
the whole display fits in a page in that
case and the other reason this was this
also the same basic screen handling
turns out also works on terminals so
from ascii terminal you can also run a
daus task and so it's a reason to keep
the to minimize the updates
whereas with x you could have afford to
update a larger the bandwidth is higher
with x that is for an ascii terminal for
example and and the the process also
works on ascii terminal
well in terms of X with X in the systems
we do clearly notice that there's more
processes involved and so stuff doesn't
run as fast as a perceptible difference
where they're at you were there running
with X or without the you know X on this
on this system the DAW simulation for
CPU intensive stuff but you know it
works very well there's very very little
degradation trapping i/o instructions
takes a significant amount of time we've
you know we're doing what we can and
making significant improvements to
minimize the number of traps that a
process takes and did that answer your
question
he's a little did we Emil ate the EGA or
or use CGA or and let me I'll explain
that we did the hardest one first
we actually emulate a CGA and if you
directly attach it we translate to EGA
and the X X always work treats it as an
eg a display but X is built on the EGA
display and we don't tend to do it on a
CGA the the resolution so low I don't
think anyone want to use it
they've had patients like like x-term
it's it's borderline it's it's slow I
don't know we've got all the speed
squeeze I don't we can but the display
is slow yeah that's a nation we believe
that yeah I believe it's it's it's just
actually the display characteristics and
I'm about out of time I'm out of time so
save your ID that up first you goofed
here I got that
[Applause]